I thought I knew everything about you
and it turns out you're a sleepwalker I
found that out today yeah and you're a
serious sleepwalker I mean you just get
so I take it serious I sleepwalk
yeah sleepwalk which is kind of
troubling because it's kind of scary
right well it's nothing you can do about
it either you do it you don't and I
happen to be one of those people who
does this is the most embarrassing one I
think I've ever done and it just
happened to me I've been flying all over
the place promoting the two biggest
box-office hits in the world [ __ ]
[Applause]
right so okay two flaws one I sleepwalk
- I'm one of the most judgmental people
in the world it's a character flaw I
can't help it I'm a very judgmental
person I so you can sleep judge yeah so
I'm getting on a plane like 5:30 in the
morning in New York to fly here and I'm
at the airport and I see the Kardashians
now I don't know anything about them I
know they are and my wife watches the
show sometimes so I've seen him on TV
and there's the Kardashians about to
board the plane Bruce Jenner the mom a
guy who I found out later was the son he
he was with them he looked like them and
he had to uh you know what he called
thought blackberries go
and he's like got two BlackBerry's going
at 5:30 in the morning at the airport
I'm like yeah that doesn't look
nefarious at all yeah so and there was
one girl with and there wasn't Kim and
it wasn't the big tall one that's all I
know right so it's the Kardashian I
immediately am like look at them look at
them in my head right I'm like that you
know talents you know I mean where do
they do further where do they add to
society nothing look at me I'm like I am
such a great celebrity you're not I mean
I'm so talented I'm such a nice guy I
contribute so much to society new board
and they've got a lot of bags and suit
bags they're being kind of troublesome
asking for kind of all kinds of help and
I go to my feet and there's a guy there
who looks like a federal marshal to be
honest with you okay and and I even give
him the like thing and he goes like
about that so I'm like yeah we all know
they suck right look at them and then
look at me yeah so now I know sometimes
when I fall asleep on a plane although
it hasn't happened in a long time that I
might have a nightmare or sleepwalk
right so I never whenever I think I'm
gonna fall asleep I don't have anything
around me I don't have water or anything
and that morning I knew
I'm fall asleep Kardashians are all over
there I'm on the left-hand side of the
plane yeah right so I tell the
stewardess no don't wake me up I
probably gonna fall asleep I get rid of
the water she gave me I got no water no
nothing I fall asleep I wake up and I'm
standing over the federal marshal guy
going
[Applause]
all the Kardashians are over in a
quarter scared crapless like this Bruce
Jenner is out of his seat and in a
karate post like this I believe that I'm
like stand over the guy and the Federal
March guys trying to grab my hands and I
turned and the stewardess is going
Dennis that has Dennis and I I have an
empty water bottle in my hand I'm
completely soaked from head to toe my
crotch is completely so the federal
marshal guy is completely soaked and he
grabs me with the stewardess and they
take me to the galley it ends up he's in
real federal Marsh of course yeah he's
like dude what the hell man and I'm like
I'm really sorry so you want drugs I'm
like no this is just me this is just me
is what I do
this is my finger I tell the stewardess
like I'm so sorry i sleepwalk she's like
you should have told us we had no idea
she said out of the blue you started
kicking the seat of the guy in front of
you and growling RRR I'm kicking the
seat right and then the federal marshal
guy grabbed you and you grabbed his
water and I opened it and stood over him
like King Kong I know you poured the
rest over yourself
so now I have to walk back to my seat at
first I'm like well Unleashed you know
it's been you know it's been so long as
I felt like I slept for so long like
we'll be landing soon she's like now we
got four hours of 40 I try to apologize
to the guy whose seat I supposedly kick
and he goes like this right and I
realize everybody's looking at me like
I'm some kind of weirdo and Bruce Jenner
has his headphones back on but he sees
me he goes that's really the only
expression he can make I would like to
apologize to the Kardashians on national
television oh my god all I can hope is
they thought it was willem dafoe on that
[Applause]